PROFESSOR: So far so good.
So here is the kind of
very entertaining thing
that happens when you try to
do some physics with this.
And this was done by two
physicists, Elitzur and Vaidman
in Tel Aviv, they
invented or fantasized
about some sort of bombs--
things that explode.
So they're called
Elitzur-Vaidman bombs.
And you could invent
different things,
but here is what an
Elitzur-Vaidman bomb is--
some sort of bomb,
and the way it works
is with a photon detector.
So there's a little
tube in the bomb,
and there's a photon detector.
And you have your
bomb, and you want
to detonate it-- you
send the photon in,
you send the photon
in through the tube.
And the photon, it's
detected by the detector.
And the bomb explodes.
On the other hand, if
the bomb is defective,
the photon goes in, and
the detector doesn't work.
The photon goes out.
Just goes through.
So that's an
Elitzur-Vaidman bomb.
And here is the puzzle for you--
suppose you have those bombs,
and unfortunately, those bombs,
after time, they decay.
And sometimes the
detectors go wrong,
and they don't work anymore.
So you have 10
bombs, and you know,
maybe five have gone wrong.
And now, you have maybe
a very important mission
and you need the bomb
that really works.
So what do you do?
Let's assume you cannot
break apart the detector--
it's just too complicated.
So you have the bombs,
and you want to test them.
If you send in a photon
and nothing happens,
the bomb is not working.
But if you send in a photon,
and the bomb is working--
explodes.
So you cannot use it anymore.
So the question that
Elitzur and Vaidman pose,
is there a way to
certify that the bomb is
working without exploding it?
Can you do that?
The answer looks
absolutely impossible.
And certainly, in
classical physics,
it's completely impossible.
You either do the measurement
to see if the detector works,
and if it works,
your lab goes off.
It's totally destroyed.
And if it doesn't
work, well, OK,
it's not a good bum anyways.
So there's no way out.
But there is a
way out, and it is
to insert this bomb in the mass
[? center ?] interferometer.
So here we go.
We put the mass
[? center ?] interferometer,
and we insert the bomb here with
the detector along this place.
D 0 and D 1 are still here.
And now, you put this,
and you send in a photon.
So let's see what happens
if you send in a photon.
Suppose the bomb is defective--
bomb is defective.
So what are the
possible outcomes?
Outcome and probability.
Photon goes to D 0--
0.
Photon to D 1, bomb explodes.
Well, we said the
bomb is defective.
So if the bomb is
defective, we said
it's like a detector that
doesn't work, and lets
the photons go through.
So if the bomb is defective,
it's as if there no bomb here,
and you have the situation
where all is open.
So there will be a probability
of 1 to get the photon to D 0--
a probability of 0 to
get the photon to D 1.
And the bomb, of course,
doesn't explode--
probability of 0.
On the other hand,
suppose the bomb is good--
bomb is good.
And then, what are the outcomes?
And what are the probabilities?
Well, you know, more or less,
what's happening already.
The bomb is good means there
is a detector that never
fails to detect the photon.
And if a photon comes
in, it will capture it--
it will block it.
The bomb will explode.
So you have your mass
[? center ?] interferometer,
and you've really done
the equivalent of this--
if the bomb is really working.
You've put a block
of concrete-- it's
going to absorb the photon.
So if the bomb is
really working,
the outcome are the following--
well, I'm sorry to say, your lab
will explode half of the times,
because the photon
on the block happens,
and bomb explodes
with probability 1/2.
On the other hand,
in this situation,
it is possible that the photon--
photon-- at D 0, and
bomb doesn't explode--
not explode.
And there is a probability 1/4.
And there is a probability,
1/4, that the photon is at D 1,
and the bomb does not explode.
But here is the catch now--
yes, half of the bombs exploded,
we're sorry about that.
But if the bomb
doesn't work, there
is no way a photon can reach
D 1, because if a bomb doesn't
work, all photons go to D 0.
So the fact that some
photons, a quarter percent
of the time, 1/4--
25% of the time--
reach D 1 implies
that photon is at D 1,
and bomb did not explode.
But the bomb is good.
So look what has happened--
it's really strange.
The photon went-- the bomb was
here, it was ready to explode.
The photons kept the
bomb, and ended at D 1,
and you still know that
the bomb works now--
even though the photon never
went through the detector.
It never touched here, it never
went inside and get detected.
Somehow it went
through the other way,
but you know that the bomb is
working, with a quarter percent
efficiency.
We will do exercises, and
it's possible to raise
the efficiency to 50%.
And if you put the bomb inside
a cavity, a resonant cavity
with photons going around,
you can reach 99% efficiency.
So the probability of blowing
up MIT goes down to 1%.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know if we
can live with that--
I don't think so.
But anyway, this
is a true fact--
experiments without
bombs have been done,
and it shows that in
quantum mechanics,
you can do very
surprising measurements.